[Musik]
hallo danke dass du so schnell kommen
konnte warum wechseln ich habe ein
problem mit meiner webseite
ich habe gestern abend ziemlich lange
versorgt mal her so bitte das hast du
mir woanders gezeigt ja schon okay
fragen technik das passt eben nicht
zusammen
immerhin kannst du fahrräder reparieren
entschuldigung ist das war ein
kompliment das wird ein kompliment
gewesen sein
du hast ja keine ahnung frauen und
technik was für ein blödes klischee okay
aber jetzt konzentriere ich mal wieder
auf die webseite also mach es so wie ich
sie gezeigt habe es ist eigentlich ganz
einfach sogar für frauen dann machst du
es schon wieder was du ja sogar für
frauen
es muss aber nicht immer alles ganz
einfach sein damit ich es verstehe es
gibt bestimmt jede menge frauen die
besser programmieren können als du ja
das kann sein aber trotzdem gibt es
unterschiede zwischen männern und frauen
und ich kenne ziemlich viele frauen die
eben nicht mit computern umgehen können
aha seien unsinn
ja ich finde die meisten frauen machen
irgendwie alles komplizierter als es ist
männer auch ich finde nicht dass das
typisch weiblich ist machen jetzt weiter
mit der webseite
ja wie wär's mit pink
[Musik]